What can you do to protect the Hokage? I'd like to see
someone who wants to meet me. I don't
know who that person is, but let me talk to that person. If
you're a temate, you're off the list. Hey, off the list of people to kill me.
If I told her that I had excluded her, the first thing she would think of would be to kill me.Because of the person who
excluded her, that means that she is
infatuated with consciousness and
has enough influence to make me obey her.Negotiate
with that person.  I want to. That's
really
cunning. There's no way I can
talk to him properly. He's
someone who has something to do with me. He's always a bastard. I was planning on taking him along
any route he's used to, but
then, let's just go. Wait a minute, you guys, do your
own thing.  Don't move forward with the conversation. Don't make it complicated. You're the one who's making it complicated. Don't you
understand?
Dad doesn't want this. I do
n't understand. You're probably doing it to
protect me.  It doesn't matter what other people think
[Music] What did you
do all of a sudden
? Enough is enough, just do whatever
you want. I understand how you feel.
I'll protect you, it's my choice.
Brother,
stop, that's
cool, but Boruto.  What are you doing?
[Music]